also früher war ja wirklich alles ganz
anders erotisch war schon der diebische
shootings im otto katalog und dann
klingelt es gibt immer ein unterschied
zwischen merck fotos oder akut ist und
den playboy fotos nichtsdestotrotz ist
der playboy dennoch nur eine andere
porno branche ist für mich einfach noch
von früher als aushängeschild zur roten
der körper wird instrumentalisiert um
begierde beim betrachter zu erreichen
haben sich verändert wenn ja haben sie
offen
papa hat dann sofort gesagt super
ästhetische fotos mega cool wenn ich das
durch blätter klar gefällt mir das als
playmate ist nun nicht automatisch im
barnim mein interesse war es nie für den
einen oder anderen ist vielleicht schon
überhaupt die darstellung nackter
tatsachen ein tabu körper einer frau ist
einfach ästhetisch eine frau die sich
für den playboy auszieht muss natürlich
mit den konsequenzen leben tatsächlich
um erlaubnis gefragt habe ich nun mein
arbeitgeber sehr polarisiert aber das
ist auch gut so
[Musik]